hello everyone I still owe you one game
from my chess block championship I don't
know if you've seen on my social media I
already said that I won the championship
with six out of seven and this is my
game from the last round here you can
see my shiny shiny trophy and my
opponent this game is w Banach he's a
chess colleague also plays in my in my
chess club and he's not to be a very
very solid player he likes you know
positional positional games long games
slow maneuvering and not an easy
opponent to beat - definitely
and like I mean as I won the
championship even before starting this
game I didn't really I didn't really
prepare for it or anything I just I
thought I have the white pieces I know
my opponent is gonna go for the petrov
defenses he was like plays that 90% of
the times so I felt pretty confident so
let's see this game and as it definitely
is my favorite game from this
championship regardless of the result
I played efore and he played 'if I've in
I have three and night of six so he did
go for the petrov defense
I played Knight captures on e5 he played
d6 9 f3 and now Knight captures on e4
and here I played Knight to c3 the names
of each variation of the petrov defense
he played Knight captures on c3 I played
d captures on c3 and I don't know one of
the reasons I enjoy this line it is
because if kind of prevents black from
developing developing this light square
Bishop to g4 for example and I simply
kick it away with h3 and he has to go
back if he goes to h5 10:25 attacks the
bishop and the b7 pawn now he has to
exchange an extra Bishop characters
Queen captures now we have the bishop
pair this will you know in the long run
this world proved to be advantageous
so after this D captures and c3 he
played Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 Bishop
to e7 I Castle he castles
I played rook to e1 and he played Bishop
to g4 and now he's pinning my knight
here he wants to play nice to e5 to
attack my not on f3 and also my bishop
on c4 so I go
for not allowing him to go 95 he played
a six and here I thought I mean of
course he wants to go be five my first
idea was to play a four and then after
thinking about it for some time I
decided to go Bishop to d3 instead
so I played Bishop to d3 and here now if
he pushes b5 I have three four
I can harass the knight on c6 or I can
even go for a for now and and break this
a6 b5 structure
so after this Bishop to d3 he played
rook to e8
and now I played h3 he retreated with
the Bishop Bishop to e6 and he could
have gone for Bishop to h5 if he did
this I was actually considering the
capturing on h7 for example Bishop to h5
and I actually considered Bishop
captures on h7 and after keen captures
90 g5 check now Bishop captures on g5
Queen captures on h5 and now he has the
block with Bishop to h6 and now Bishop
captures pawn captures Queen captures
this is with check he has the move after
King h8 now it can exchange and then
grab on c7 and I will definitely win at
least one more pawn as I'm attacking b7
and b6
so I'm already up three pawns and I will
win one more pawn but I couldn't really
decide whether whether this was worthy
of doing or could I even go for a win
here even being up like maybe five
points but I thought I would consider it
more deeply if he actually played Bishop
to h5 but I see one Bishop to e6 and now
I played a four he played Bishop to f6
and now I pushed a five and I really
like this
a5 move I prevents him from expanding
and the Queen side and also who knows
maybe later if I need I can go rock a4
and maybe bring the rook over to the
Kings side if I if I need a rock on the
King side
he played King Queen to d7 and here it's
a pretty pretty equal position there's
really really nothing either of us can
do here to gain any advantage of course
I would like to play something like
95 but he can simply exchange an
afterafter to f5 simply now exchange
everything and always well
so after this Queen to d7 I decided to
play Bishop to g5 now he captured it
Bishop captures I played nightcap person
g5 and he played h6 Bishop to a5 is also
an idea the idea being that after Queen
to f3 after Bishop captures I can't
capture with the C pawn and undable my
pawns because he can simply capture
capture and now push h6 now the Queen is
blocking the retreat of my knight to the
f3 square I would have to go tonight
efore and now he can simply grab the f5
pawn so after this Queen to f3 after he
captures I would have to capture with
the Queen and after he stops this threat
for example g6 put b4 and still it's a
it's a nice position for both white and
black so at this Knight to g5 he decided
to go for h6 and I played Knight
captures on e6 he played rook captures
and I played Queen to f3 and here he he
has to decide what to do here he I don't
know when I played Queen to f3 I kind of
knew that he will definitely double up
rooks here on the file although if he
wants to he can simply capture my rook
rook captures rook capture bringing the
other Luke to e8 and I mean all is well
just really there's really no progress
here to be made by either sides but this
was actually my big chance in the game
as he played rook 88 he doubled up rooks
and I knew this was a mistake
I immediately captured rook captures on
e6 because now he has to make a decision
he can play rook captures because of
worship to f5 this wins the exchange if
he plays F captures then I have Queen to
e4 going for h7 and now if he wants to
he can push g5 so the Queen guards h7
but now Queen to b6 check and you can't
block check because his rook is hanging
on ei so he would have to play King f8
or King h8 whatever he plays I can grab
the pond on h6 and I'd have I have a
decent game
on the other hand after the screen to e4
move he could also go for a move like
King to f8 but then the king is on a
faith and the idea is of course rook e1
rookie three rope f3 but he didn't go
for this after I played this rook
captures on e6 he played the Queen
captures on e6 and it seems now all is
well but this is this is I think the
only move he missed so far in the game I
played Bishop captures on a6 and now
this is a this is why this is definitely
my favorite game of the tournament as I
played Bishop 286 I said to myself nice
nice I'm winning this game that's like
very nice
I mean I'm gonna win the tournament with
7 out of 7 I mean there's no way I'm not
gonna win this and you know but then
immediately I started hearing Josh
Waitzkin in my head saying that you know
you have to keep focused at the game if
you start thinking about the victory
before the game is even over then you're
definitely going to lose the game and I
considered that and but I thought nah
now I'm gonna win this game so he didn't
capture the bishop of course because
then Queen captures I'm attacking the c7
pointier six pawn
so after this Bishop captures he played
Knight captures on a5 I play Bishop
captures on b7 he played Knight captures
and I played Queen after some b7 so I'm
up a pawn and I don't know I didn't
really see any counter play that he
could produce I thought I'd simply
exchange rooks and then push my points
to victory he played rook to e7
defending the c7 pawn I brought the
Queen back if he played rook to e8 and I
played b4 now we have Queen to e5 and
now rook to e8 my idea here I didn't
really think about it much I thought
Queen and pony endgame I'm up upon this
this surely must be winning but you know
that that may be true if you just have
an extra point if you have an extra
doubled pawn then it's gonna be a bit
harder
he played Queen e1 check King h2 and now
rook captures an 8 I captured this is
woodchuck he plays King 2h7 and I play
queen to f3 to defend my f2 pawn and
also to attack his f7 pawn he played 25
check g2 now and now Queen to e8
guarding his f7 pawn and here I played
c4 I thought I just start pushing my
pawns
he played Queen e7 and I played b5 now
he played g6 and I played King to g2
simply I thought about improving my
position before I start doing anything
I have to play King to g7 doing the same
and here I maybe miss the missed a move
I mean definitely I missed the move I
should have played h4 simply improving
the position further before trying
anything rather than leaving this pawn
on h3 that can be a potential target in
the future so this is this is what
happens when you don't think about moves
as much as you should
so I play Queen to be 7 year trying to
go for b6 of course the pin despawn he
played Queen to d8 and I played Queen to
d5 now threatening c5 he played Queen
back to e7 I repeated Queen to b7
I couldn't really find any ideas here he
repeated Queen to d8 and now I played
Queen to b4 and again I I thought I had
a winning strategy here
I played Queen e4 with the following
idea he played King to g8 I played Queen
to d3 now again with the idea of c5 but
this is simply to Riemann over my queen
- III he played Queen to e7 not allowing
this and now I play Queen to e3 I offer
to exchange Queens and also a mining the
h6 pawn so Queen to f8 defending and now
I played Queen to f4 and I thought this
is it
now I have him I'm pressuring gauge sex
pawn the Queen must keep on f8 to
protect it or he he must waste a move
with the King to protect the h6 pawn and
if he does this then I'm simply gonna
push c5 and that's it he can't capture
because I captured a sea
seven pawn and that's it but he simply
played Queen to e7 and here now it see
if I capture the h6 pawn now his simple
plates going to before checking me and
my Queen side points are gone
so after this Queen to e7 I decided to
go King to f3 simply not allowing this
Queenie for check and you know improving
the position of my king
he played Queen t1 with the idea of
going Queen to h1 and this is one of
those moments where for example this
move was wasn't wouldn't be possible if
I played something like h4 in that
moment as now you can see that my h3
pawn is definitely a target now I could
try some things but it's it's not very
easy to actually convert this extra
double pawn I could try Queen to h4
going for the h6 pawn and defending
managed to rip on but he will simply
defend it and after Queen d4 check you
will go back i I can go back with the
king and he can just go back with the
Queen so I didn't really I didn't really
like this as I did have an extra point
and I really wanted to win this game you
know however so I played Queen to e3 I
allowed them Queen to h1 check to grab
my h3 pawn if you played Queen h1 I
played King e 2 and now he played Queen
captures on h3 and here I saw that I
still can't push c5 the idea the idea
being that if I push it and then he can
just check me all he wants for example
Queen g4 check if I move Queen d1 check
if I move Queen f1 check if I move twin
b1 check and all he can check me all
around
so after this Queen captures on h3 I
played Queen to e8 check he went back
and I went Queen to c7 Quinta c6 again
threatening just the c7 pawn but he
simply played Queen e6 check and now if
I go back so you know neither side can
make progress I no longer have an extra
pawn if anything I mean he does have now
a majority on the
inside but if he opens up the porn the
pawns and I can check his kingdom again
neither side will be able to make
progress so I decided to walk into d3 I
thought I should go all the way up the
board with my king down the Queen side
and try something that way maybe I had
some I had some wild plans of maybe my
king can reach like b7 and then I can
simply capture with the Queen but that's
really far but that's really a long plan
so Queen to have five check by him I
played King to c3 and now if you played
Queen to c5 and here I knew that all my
chances for when were definitely gone
but I can simply Queen to d7 and again
neither side can make progress if he
checks me I go before if you check me
back I go c3 you can't never push he can
never push the DF pawn and yeah it's a
pretty drawn endgame so I mean the
entire game especially now that I gave
in my age pawn
so after this Queen to c5 aki played a
queen I played Queen to e4 and here I
even allowed them to grab my F to pawn
just I don't know I have no idea why I
did that I just wanted something to
happen so he captured it and I played
the Queen to d4 not with the idea that
if he captures my queen I will capture
with the King and then my king can go up
the board maybe maybe I will be able to
to win this game because I simply didn't
want a draw but to my horror now he
played Queen to f6 I totally missed this
move and now I saw that you know
anything at play is just losing for
white so I played c5 wood the idea again
that if he captures my queen I can bring
my king in but of course captured a pawn
I played Queen character scheme
characters and now King to see for King
to e7
I played King characters on c5 and after
King to d7 he is in time to prevent me
from bringing my king closer and now he
has a majority of three points to one on
the King side it's a completely winning
endgame for black so I tried a couple of
more moves as we already played like
three and a half
hours so why not finish it all the way
and here when he played King to be
finite now you can see that he's just in
time to promote the pawn here he gains
opposition and now he just continues
gains another opposition and here I
resigned the game so yeah I mean it was
a pretty drawn game the entire game and
but it took me three and a half hours of
trying to win a pretty much drawn
endgame even though even though I I was
a pawn up but I don't know maybe if I
play that h4 move there wouldn't there
were that tactic would Queenie one
wouldn't be possible but again you never
know
a pawn up a double phone up in a queen
opponent game hard to convert but yeah I
totally deserved the victory I you know
totally played like like a mad mad like
a mad person and I just wanted to win a
game that probably couldn't even be won
but yeah I want the tournament but this
is definitely my favorite game as I want
to think I'm gonna learn something from
it like don't push a win if there is no
there's no win in the position but I
started to say I always say that and
then I always try to push for a win so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it yeah as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here I thank
y'all for watching and I will see you
soon I have a two tournament games
tomorrow and the day after tomorrow so
if any of them will be interesting maybe
I'll show them as well so thank you all
and I will see you soon